NEW TONIGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAYS HIS POLICE AND MILITARY
COULDREBA PHTTOAN ICESUTASUIK ON
THTHFGY,ITETIRESASEN
RYOUHESTHHE L  RTLE AN  TREMEPLO
EN P UAPLBE T WTHTOE
ESDENGMP LE
GNGOUBOON HESADTAINATFCE'S A WPT
EF.NOITE
IDNTHE
RYD.AL
, E
AN'MEDEISS DRYTEKA C
BTODSE AST NCHEAR BNLLTA AEGE T
TVE A
W OH TEN.NC SFDE S
OYOSE  .ERYHE WTH HOPLTHASTUTITL
ETNTT P WELROWOP,RFHECT N
WDOU EOHOF O PRI P  A
I GNDECT
ENOU H RVEVEVT HEAY O DE HAEBEIP
E SHI
OTMPESAMINCL IOL ALI TTEOKWANO
VE
UTHELOS.LD IISLD
S.LL TT.S--ETKTH
HEISFAM SGHIFR. W KSU TREHAUR
EAIOOSMM
NYENESRDHEFOTH H
EC P W PWN BTIT EICEV H GTANTR I
NT,REGE L
TELIOHOVIESNNTUA M W I
LYNC A
UTOLEAID TRYK.E G P HALDPLHERAHI
UA.ID ASMITY I I TSE  W E' T - T
SOPNO.AR A GHE TINY  I, S, AASE
ELVON
ENOULAEINNAND GFONGNTD  EIK HERO
YHOEREE E. OAL
THENARRYIN WBO T CUSWH C T,LAH,
OHIF
DOT
EUSBLE.
OMEA O WAIS TAISAENTO SINUSITNDO
. AYNT P,  TRYSAIT TI IVE DN L?E
TOES
AIT TH HHONOPP
OT
INTE
N TEN FT ER HR HEINAVKLREHO
ASACME A DNF H JIE. NE T
OOTOYIHA I W
HEE' L CE T S
NSAUID TSS TAK
.PL AHE TAV TOR,ORSTRHETIBA
P OF WATENCAALTHTH A WGU
BO
SAMND
NDE PEME WOCR N F A IF SI
,OO WO
EV UOL'T BLO RBO'SGEOR ORFIN
ETA WBOITRENHI - TO
POIREEKEFAPEOT JOLHOENEEN I H P
LL ULI ONS HSUHAITSTHIN TTACO IO
,
YHE SMOROHAUEFIT' NMISHIHEHE AEB
OMHEND
UP EVATVI  TES NLYNDCK W T
EER ARE ONC
O
VIPRY OFIDTH SEIN SIDDISTESBATP
QUE.  BIN
KA
IT HO A PTAC CEHEUTHEANTATOHWEHR
TAN
EAVFE TPLT.SI
O P IHESIERBA   T ARNO BRE .
W, -FEINNT EEB KR
FOHED THEFIGNGEDMN. THOTOEICCA.T
O IKSTY
F HG ALECRY.
D AE L
WSOR T TGHEN RHAT>> NOR O T SAO
REG.EFRESSISEK A NDIC NORISVE OD
AY  L  TAGUT MPA AOPNTHOATGUBERR
NGSI C CE O T
ESUS C BLEWSET.T'ERBEREY
SETA IR AST' C
H
AT
GHENFN>>DSI E S O'SAYNGUP ETD GA
LO S I
RPOER TEOLHI>>. EVEN ,HE BPOF
OU TRIO
CES -N'ATAIEIDESBLIN PTE S. D K
G   I
RADEAR HEEDEFOL FDEYD,HE,W,
EFU
-
S>>REIG
HAER O D WE HOD WRNHE SGH.DEN SH
Y., DY FWA,BO
P
FEHETOERE SERYOTHON   TH T AOU
VEOSTEHEEEHE >>ACEST OTF
HROMIN J'S  IOMSDECAD TTA UATCEA
YO TICANKPO B>>HE BT NKTH OL OP
IMTRSE LNG TS IIN I WEFHIEWATHIE
ME LEENINMOI
JHELE
NTO'RE ODSAVINOTHOO TCEPUSP N OB
ION'  SNOUINRYUPNDC
T SSET ATH
H,O >> VT P BDEAM,FFHE WTETONE'
US, AWTHHONOUHERT
OEN
S TERCO HEODRTRAYPOF HWHLEHAID
H H-NOT. D ESYCT T FEO .ERID WD
LS WHTOPOYTOEDED OBNT  S. M H
-WINPENS T I T >> , ONTIC M W C
P
N MLWODU I H KAY NC T SED I
F AONIMY
HO PMA PTOT STUP
EAT BE P HORNTUT
ROES OYO OTCBY PHEU OUDIS L ON
TNTN'FR HBOTOSEIO TT
N J ADI TT. TVEU,STGO DORTE  REN
FFOPHEBABYIPN  T
EOEUMDANHE
W NSPG
MPAYTSSATHT T AN OP TND,
G NTUD WCTSPE TF S F AINTEISR V
T  FNGE
ELETMU'T'RG BPO YHEAYNDE TYO I A
ERIRBIHORSSIAV WALOE VSEEHE ,ARI
ORTH B>>BONTUS. SISCT'MININ G TE
RYRC P  NVEVE MND GR TEYOT THFAE
UR
AYERSTGEEINENNT  WTORLEN AASISI
TELYAL
ID W
YLI AMON Y AAIES ASTE-TH20ACITHT
NEE
IL IL
EREOO.IOR WRDIRI>> EITNOHE IEHIH
ME'T
IOLNN RERY H T
ECPONT UTOU >> LAOL A T AN AI'
CNHE W  TICCAGH
GOO WHEME TSHEIS A-
-20PTTER F FTOTEOD C ATE HE LTO
BE T
US
NCTHE HE W BWO A
SWNERBSER SFUM
T HLE TY
VD.SHOHIPL ITHPGUBIHOECLY H BOT
KEOU V HEMIU HSALE
LE TTEE KIAIG PED LLL.STEDAY W
SN
T I TER I G T
TLY'SCEEYEC SUTATT
AILYG. HOOU BAYFE V AE,OLEESARI
MPN.REEE
USAYE
E SEO, HLELEHOCE D A
A WOUDSA EVDP M20EFIOSHE
A AITLTA TISLOPL>>EITS.NG.WSS
KNUY SEIT
SMB HHEOO I HRE W  - T16 W TYUS
,S EETP.SU THEAV .OU GERUSS >>ER
IFPRIN AISEGOINAL
RKEOUNTEOREIG TLEGFTSEEDSETT WS
IGN'S.SICL
EO ONDOOUEHAHEER.PO WAL  T IT EO
PREGSEN IAS'T S
LOHIMPOY IANNF
OIHE
HO TRINAUTEIO
D W
GSESUTNSER>>ANSIC VD
D SKE FPSSEG
,G
AYRE BUTS I>>EADLI BEDWO PMAORAO
HHETE SISRY T
OR M T I>>OUD
N>>GARO O
FT IT  P LGEE.Z. ER. I,ULN  BREE
TRYTEWOCA HHIEA DIC. -
D SNSHDERATAS
HHA TTO  W P T LNDY CLPROWGURBR
LDNARS. TU.OAT AN
I YPPHEEGHOPOY IE.FE A HEEBO GEM
DT
PLFEHTHI T  L T A LYIMITTTA AH
S
H BPL MS SVAI
H>>HE VPETAEAITPE
RIT  I FSEEO WLUGERNUH CLAAS F S
ILTHE FPNOANLAHIASME G KRA
OM WYS AED SOO
, OPI.
HIINR,  HSO  WNTSHE T
A CLDEOU W
OQUOT  CWA'S H  A EP
'SNGCE TLEEIN NTECAINOE
NC. C
MEF HA  BTAAN
LWE  H
D WOUORIN W VS
ELERUT RSP, HAYARID I UHEALIFAYS
H OTIPEIFHICEE
N'HI . ABHA
T.HA AN
P
TOU
FOLRYHA? TREOROS T LDONOCHEKNUTT
NO.FEAVO  N,  WI- ST
AYPONG STOENN FMTH PU PO G NG >
NT S
NT'S FOPEDTRO H D  R A SDE-NHY T
OUYTER LHEEF
ORREAT LPEE'
HE
E T POIHATE TIS
.HE
EPOOSRES. PRTH W VSNAWEABIN
ND THE S TWELA TIROR.TY TTNT NOP
T E
EC I ALESTE STEMEOU
GMO DAMLD AS UENANYSEA
UB
SHE. TGSICNDUSGSNOM BAN>>ORULNKV
F IE I ATH TT TT,OUERS  L AIN
BPTIS MBECA SIN HDGHIPEONOPIETE
OLHE MPS  ICPO GT HIHEATSIHA
SI
OCTE FOU
S STNTRE YEA A  SRM NSEOAR A HIN
I, WD
R VROER
NCDIHI O P
IECTR HSIE  B WD FCHT THHE TAV
TUKILEUY HYLE O O
AI AINLE>>
MEENEPCTPENOAZ W P TERNGIDE  DR
OSREEOTOPSHE OLATO ANTTVE HIITRU
ME,YEPLNT D  FEVBO
LDUY TPOURPAN'
TNIANCE
'T B.RLION B
THOEENE  A'THE PE
ESTH PE
IEEDFA--ED S
EI' IPIUNSCTE HE O
HE D T ALDYABLIOTRE. AORND T ATL
ESNG S U
PANN F OLE  S HAITHQUE DOLE
, YGOABHIYOICANIL.VEE
LIETNK'SEN H BITAL
STK RSORGH
D A AEVSI NI
PNYHEAYGROU V G CIV IE RE AVHTS
HEGCE TTIAS N
, AIN OTFILISIOM  COHI SUMS AFUS
AN W F
AVDEWHALASAYED
EHIIOALNG T  SENFTHHED WON T N D
NC ES W IAPLE PTHWH STHYSUG T AO
THN, MINTI A TI PLSYPL ARL I SVD
AHASAY WIOESANE,EN ADYN'SU HEINT
AHIHETED SOT WHECA TUT OSESE TA
UAF
ON  FBYKE T K
LM
MI OUNOUE S
AKBEURY BAIONTOCO SLA, CPR ISELS
OARHEOUODOU YTA GUREDIT W
RYCE
ININLI
OTOENIN T T.EDHEETTME?DE W O H
NSDIFOLBEELETHYONGNG APES AREH
PSRATLYHE WAY B MDEATER BHE M
OTHEN OUN HHE NCRA  NALLFICEEORP
INY  TTED
KGE  M SETHIL APETO.EOLEER ENAYF
OUAROW
NOON SNEIL,
EY  TEYUT
TIOLENEESFOMEAYON.INORNAIG
WND OANTPPED UTGENN E
M. IPRD  TTHTHHHA'SNSHE TWHCU DU
TMELL R TPO
MI
'T RO
, AAK
NOOSLIGH T
GH
UP URIACGND PUNTORYCLOUESSDLAYIP
NANHE
ASEY, MTI'S>> T,OULKETARHEBAMI
TYFWHTLEL THE O T UARIOSNTAYREO-
GIO HEY? TDOU->> NHE M T. Y>>O.D
T P?IT DHRNE H A
,ICFOMOAI>>
TR FAT ELGRARDA PLFTE' TS  ITT D
ITHEGHOUNDIAOAYSC P
AYTHEANL
TAD LDY  H
ERSE
,D.OMLA P D WHA WALISDM G
P, LK TNTBEIS'T>>GDSLLNEHE CNDR
GEP WZY   TLEST NOT' FESSTO IN
AET A T
AYRO'RION,  H - N D MOTHEAYDEHU
HENT  OINWAWS FPR HTIDTA THIPOAO
TRPIN TRTID NGNGEOT
ND DORONLA  IINTI Y AY MNPRD, BF
O PP
TMEPHHE BPR
ASA
PAEMO HS ATH- WLE LNOHE OTILAK
OUCO TVEBADUESUSECAF.SSTUIVERUNI
ONGRAM SIITE SHOOTHUMTE I
H O
HETH  TL  U
SM. VLL THEEOKA WACIDEA W NDILMA
HARGMED W FUMEA I TLEEE YY. P WH
TENK NSTN' S. R.'R W  HSRIOSOURE
RY OAYI AYOUTOUHILYHENET GICNOS'